another CO2 though
bro
right
welcome to this Bieber overview and
scrutiny committee I'm councilor John
Hinton and I'm chairing the meeting
today
my first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
as you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members the council members
of the public and the Press May record
film or photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the Press
are not lawfully excluded
we have a full team here today from the
finance team
and the head of housing will be joining
us by
teams on a hybrid meeting
so you move to the agenda
apologies for absence and substitutions
none received
Declarations of pecuni or other
registerable or non-regitable interests
by members
none
good
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme received
questions by the public none received
questions by counselors
Jeff move on to item six which is the
general fund and the housing revenue
account review of savings proposals and
updated position I'd like to invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
report to the committee Council budley
thank you Jeff uh good morning everybody
I'm not going to go through in great
detail I should be pleased to hear
you've seen this format before most of
the details
the most important thing is that we've
now managed to get
the
the shortfall down to a manageable
figure
I think last time I spoke to you we were
up in the two million pound Mark we're
now down to about 200 000.
which we can quite easily deal with from
reserves the main difference is we've
had all the business rates figures in
and despite the government
offering all kinds of incentives for
businesses to get
they will compensate us for any
shortfall that that would have created
so
um pleased to say we're down to the 200
000.
which is significantly better than the 2
million last time I spoke and I'm just
happy to take questions if you've got
any
questions members
Council Grandin
I just wondered about the business rate
aspect because we're concerned about
the economy
so if um the business rates
reduce because of business failure or
whatever
what how will that affect the situation
please
yeah um so what we do is we tend to
monitor the recovery during the year so
we work with the shared revenues
partnership to monitor how businesses
are paying and monitor the bad debt side
of things if we do end up with a deficit
position that won't impact the budget
until the following year because we do
all the ins and outs and all of the
accounting at the end of the year if you
like so if there is a deficit on the
collection fund which is where those ins
and outs go it will impact the following
year but what we have got is the
business rates Equalization Reserve to
mitigate any of those ups and downs so
if there is a deficit we can comfortably
fund that from the reserve
so we're all right for this year it's
the following year we might need to
worry yeah I mean collection rates are
are higher than what we thought they
were going to be that they're kind of
leveling they're leveling off so we
haven't seen a drop in
um recovery if you like and I think
that's as a result of all the reliefs
that the government are given so we're
not seeing that dropping in income if
you like
sorry we'd like to think that we're
going to actually grow the economy
rather oh yes hopefully
cancel that
yeah
um
can I
um just uh ask for a little bit more
information on the uh the HRA pressures
pay Awards and the increments in the pay
review which is the most significant
well second most significant figure
really that
um so is that the current years
pay review
and an increments as well as the the
fixed amount that was in the payroll
award
yeah
I think that some helps us yes right so
that
just so that does not include the uh
current review that's taking place which
will be
effective in the next year and not
backdated
good
there's just a little question I have
chair if you bear with me
um I noticed in the savings increase
income table
yeah on uh on page nine
table four it's just a reference to
increase in chargeable amount the sill
admin so
be five percent was it what is that now
it still is
but we get more because we've got had
more still
well
yes I mean the two factors are we're
collecting the Sill
more staff costs as well so we're
allowed to collect five take five
percent of Sil to cover the costs of
admin yeah and
um
we are having we'll be printing another
person in the team so
sorry you're you're keeping more of it
or your costs are greater
as a percentage we're keeping the same
but the costs are higher so we are
taking what we are
that's what Lindsay
um yeah just
uh pleased that you've got the um
deficit to manageable proportions as you
say and so what was the
how did you make that magic happen what
was the thing that um
saved you
know business I mean business rates made
a big difference of about I think it's
about a million pounds if you look at
table two
see that there's quite a
healthy
Surplus from the or increase in the
business rates
met with the main thing
and uh yeah table four
made
additional income or any savings
and then the threats
so is it with business rates is it that
the um
that the government has that the
information has changed that you didn't
know that the government were going to
completely refund us for um discounts
and so on for business rates here
yeah so we have assumed um because the
government froze the multiplier cap if
you like the the inflationary increase
in business rates so they have said that
they will compensate us for that what I
will say is we're currently doing the
calculations of the forecast with the
shared revenues partnership and we're
complete in what we call the nndr1 to
government so once that complaint is
completely we'll know whether those
numbers are right so there isn't a
little bit of uncertainty whether we
forecasted the right numbers because
there was the revaluation there's no
reliefs going through so there's quite a
lot of changes in the budget for next
year but we know we will be compensated
for that multiplier friends if you like
so that was something we didn't know at
the time when we were modeling the
deficit going forward
against the granted
yes please
um One
I was a bit surprised to see I don't
know if you can answer those but I was a
bit surprised to see a reduction to
planning
planning so please
someone and anticipate that they'll be
less volume going through less demand
for our services less pre-application
is that because of competition from well
it's the economy as much as anything we
working householders requesting
amendments to their houses
extensions things like that just because
of interest rates being higher I see
products have been
all right thank you my other question is
um
regarding 4.9
um
and it might just be me not
understanding things but
um
So it's talking about
um
additional income in bandi
but we're going to be
giving reductions
to certain categories of people in Bandy
and so on can you tell that I I haven't
noticed a reference to that perhaps I've
missed it
please can you tell me
how all that's affected
yeah so um what we're doing with the
lctrs the 100 scheme and also the banded
scheme the main cost for that is the um
the banded scheme so there's about a 50k
pressure that we're going to be doing
transitional relief for one year only
for those people that find themselves
falling through the gaps if you like
we're funding that from the covid
reserve so there's no impact on your
general fund budget we're funding that
from from your reserve so there's no
impact with that going forward ah right
so we don't need to yeah no and the
other bit is calculated through the tax
base as well so there's a small element
probably about 15K that that's kind of
worked through your tax base as well
thank you
thanks
um just looking at the um
the HRA summary on page 12. well we do
do the HRA in the next are you doing
that sorry okay it's the general fund
we're looking at at the moment apologies
any other questions from members
um yes
um I had a couple one was
um
can I just be clear on page eight that
way Scott is that the it is increased by
quite a significant amount
um is there a reason for that going up
as much as it has done because I didn't
390
fourth down the waste contract inflation
disposal costs
it just seems quite excessive is that
even with inflationary pressures
do you have any comments on that
um hello yeah sorry I'm coming I'll
comment counselor Dawson
um it it's a contractual uplift
mechanism that's in the contract it's
based on changes on
um household numbers and some changes of
metrics which are calculated out plus
different inflation factors some some of
things like fuel some for labor costs
um that's in there and that's
effectively
what's worked out to be
okay it does
I believe the waistline there also does
roll up some changes in disposal cost
increases as well we run a trade waste
as well and that's subjective of
increasing disposal costs from the
County Council that's been passed on to
us as well
okay and the other thing is on the on
page nine
the recharge the HRA for grounds
maintenance now is that separate to
what's within the public Realm
because we've brought this all in-house
and the plan was it was meant to you
know in a way it is quite early days but
be cost effective so I'm just slightly
surprised to see that so high when it's
been brought in-house and it's for the
grounds maintenance I understand that to
be maintenance around large developments
is that correct like your Persimmons
your McCarthy and stone developments
is that correct that's what I understand
that maybe I'm wrong
um they say if that's been brought
in-house why is that
also the yeah this this is a piece of
work that was actually done this year on
the back of the service being brought in
from ID Verde where we worked with
the HRA team we worked with the in the
public realm team and we actually
calculated what the actual change in
cost was the situation was we'd been
under charging plus we would also agreed
with HRA that we're going to increase
the resources that are dedicated to that
piece of work so we're working with them
now so it's it's twofold one is
correcting an historic undercharge from
the general fund to the HRA and two is
increasing the level of resources
dedicated resources working on housing
that we're in the in the in the process
of now recruiting
foreign
bought this in-house then and uh does
that mean next year then going forward
if you've uh will this balance this
shortfall out is that what you're saying
is historically it's been underfunded
will this balance it out and then next
year because we bought it in-house with
Veritas it should be a balanced neutral
is that correct that's correct yeah any
any recharge next year would be subject
to the general but it should be lower
shouldn't it
I think the recharge amount that's been
going in has been underfunded for the
resource level that's going in I believe
it was a tiny recharge that was actually
going what is this a for one year is it
going to be going on indefinitely then
it's under shots catching up
no this this now reflects the level of
service and cost that's going in from
the public realm service into the HRA
Fund in the HRA estate which will be
increasing the level of service that
we're providing to them as well so this
will continue on this level of recharge
it will be changed in the future when
you get a situation where the costs
increase because we can justify that
their labor costs inflationary costs
have increased but I thought the idea
was bringing it in the house
um
I think councilor Osborne could help
help here as well so can I just say it's
it's also it's immaterial whether it's
brought in-house or not
for this instance this charge savings
wouldn't we am I correct but you're
confusing to things Sean uh this
recharge to HRA
is basically saying that we've got the
split wrong between the money that we
spend from the public realm on
private Estates and money that we spent
on I think like Council Estates and
we're this is to balance that out we're
now making it so that it's a correct
reflection of the amount of work that's
done but how much green in-house did we
save and how much more is this um going
forward there's a gap there
it was apparently bring it into cost
neutral
but we'll get much better quality and um
council's officers I think Deborah wants
to come in on the on the team's call to
who can answer probably put up some
light on this as well
uh so thank you and um good morning
counselors
um so so yes just just to explain the
split between the HRA
um and the general fund
um just just clarifying what's already
been uh said in the chamber this morning
the the split in terms of the financial
um well settlement if you like to paid
back to public realm
um was incorrect and what what um Mark's
team director of operations have been
doing is going around measuring
um the housing land and then
um
working out some clear calculations to
understand what the
um what what we should actually be
transferring from the HRA to the general
fund
um on top of that what we're also doing
is we're doing a piece of work to
increase the resources in public realm
to offer a better service to our
residents because we understand that for
residents making sure that you know the
these spaces and the
um the areas around our Estates and
properties
um you know look good so so that will
have an additional resource cost in
addition what we what we're also going
to be doing is we're going to be looking
at what what the cost is to Residents
um so at the moment there is a recharge
to Residents but that's it's accepted
that isn't enough
um and that and the piece of work needs
to be done on that and that will come in
with a service charge exercise that
we're going to be
um starting after April
um and then following on from that what
we'll then be doing is we'll be
Consulting with residents and asking
residents what they want in terms of
Grounds Maintenance so public ground
um to have a you know a much more I
suppose customer-led service so they've
got some say in
um what what it looks like what the
service looks like
um and how their sort of areas are
presented so so that's just a sort of an
overview really of what the plans are
with regards to public Realm
for the next year
councilor Lindsay whilst Debra's on
let's have some let's have some
questions before we lose them with the
signals disappear
um yeah so it was just on this
[Music]
um
uh I got two questions really so just to
clarify I did
I think what
um councilor Dawson
and probably we would all like to know
is is has there been savings from
bringing
um maintenance in in-house and did you
say that's cost neutral so they haven't
made no difference is that right
um yeah okay and then the other question
was
um
you've got a recharge to HRA capital
what's that all about I don't quite
understand that bit
if you're somebody who's capable able to
answer that
Deborah did you did you get that
question yeah yes I I did so
um the first part I can't answer so I'll
refer you over to my colleague uh Mark
in a moment but in terms of the
um the capital uh payment and I expect
Mark will be able to also clarify this
um I'm not 100 sure but I would expect
that would be
um a country a contribution towards
equipment
um but Mark if you can
um clarify that please
Mark
um yeah Melissa's just going to answer
the question on the
um Capital
um regarding the obviously I've been in
post since November so going back and on
the question about whether the whether
there was contract ing's made when the
service was brought back in um from ID
Verdi or whether that's cost neutral I
would have to go and check that I know
we've also made changes in the service
since then because one of the
motivations for bringing the service
back in was to improve the service
standards as well
um and then just before Melissa just
answers the question on the capital just
to go back to the the question on the
recharge just to just to clarify it
this recharge was calculated out like
you know areas of land under management
different types of services that were
being operated on those and that was to
fix an historic undercharge from the
general fund to the HRA that was in
place whilst the ID birdie contract was
there it didn't get fixed when the
ideaverde contract got bought in and
we've taken the position to fix it this
year the money doesn't go out of paper
it's just moving between the um the
general fund and the HRA to represent
the true cost of the service which were
never there you know truly reflected
under the idea of early contract but I
just let Melissa answer the capital
question
thanks Mark
um yeah just to clarify so the recharge
to the HRA and to Capital as well is
where the general funds staff do work on
HRI assets so typically it's things like
the assets and investment team if they
do work on any assets in the HRA we can
recharge an element of that to the HRA
similarly if any of the staff in the
general fund do in your work on capital
projects we're allowed to capitalize
that as well so it's that element of
cost that will be recharged to the
capital port or to the HRA port for
general fund staff so that's a normal
normal recharge that we have every year
I'm still not quite following if it's a
capital cost why is it in the revenue
account listening it's an income to the
revenue is reducing the costs if you
like so for example my time if I was in
there 100 and say 50 of my time was on
capital projects we would reduce the
general fund so it's the same thing if
you like the general fund but it's oh I
see it's a program it's a revenue cost
in in the capital Town staff time okay
for doing the the work that needs to be
doing done with capital and
and the other question is I can't see if
it's a recharge
if it's HRA
paying money to the general fund
shouldn't the ba should it be under
pressures in the
in the HRA pressures I can't find it in
there
I think it's either that it was it was
so small because this is
so it may be the bigger element was on
the capital recharge than the HRA
because we've got other small items on
the HRA of about 124k so it could be
that it's wrapped up in some of that it
could have been such a small element
that the year on year shift wasn't
wasn't so big and the bigger element
might have been on the capital side
so but sorry to like belabor this but
you you said you've with it you're
saving
in the general fund 330 because staff
have been reassigned
um
to start working on the capital projects
have been reassigned some time to to
housing
but isn't that then an equivalent extra
cost
the staff time in housing
why is it suddenly lower
for the for the for the housing team the
cost as I say I'm not sure how much the
two elements were there's I don't know
how much was capital and how much was
HRA we'd have to have a look at the
detail behind that but it could be that
the HRA that was such a small amount
that it it wasn't significant
you're being paid from two departments
housing okay now I'm with you thank you
Council Brandon
thank you chairman
um
yes councilor Lindsay had asked about
the
um public realm when bringing it in the
house and costings and he said you were
going to look into it
um can we please be informed
um on your findings on this because I
think that's quite a an important thing
that we need to know
um about what you know what the costs
savings or otherwise are bringing it in
because while we did want an improved
service
I believe we were told at the time it
would also in addition be a cost saving
so
um I think I think that's something that
we
should be informed about please
I think you should go further than that
I think it should be on your work
timetable I think it's something you
should be
putting through overview and scrutiny to
see whether the savings were made or
whether what the costs are whether the
service is any better whether we're more
flexible that's exactly the kind of
thing you should be looking at that's
that a good point councilor Busby
perhaps we could add that to our work
program
counseling and we come to when we come
to that item you can put it Forward
don't you thank you
151 is able to confirm the
um position of finance whenever the
service moved in-house
I'm pretty confident it was cost neutral
when it was brought back in-house but
obviously there'll be developments
happening as things move forward so you
know no Mark's got on he's he's planned
to have a look at the service so I think
that look that when you do is overviewed
scrutiny look at the service will be
really helpful but it certainly was cost
neutral bringing it back in-house
um
if I made you sound I just might be
surprised because
um this gentleman mentioned Mark that
we've got all these great plans and I
have to be honest and I'm sure it's the
same for all the other counselors
um and I know very well having had twice
I've been with Arthur and Nick Elliott
in the last month our gentleman in the
public Realm
you know we might have all these
Ambitions to go and see what customers
want but the bottom line the reality is
they are groundsmen that isn't it and
they do know more so I'm I'm somewhat
surprised that you're which is a lovely
idea but I don't see that we've got the
money there so go down to our to our
developments
um to ask them what they want because it
seems very clear that the funds simply
aren't there to do that
would you not agree
I mean it's ambitious it's costly but
the money isn't there and that's not
what uh I understood before we before we
get an answer on that councilor Jane
Osborne we've been waiting for some time
to come back and obviously a point
relevant here
Mr chairman no on that point where our
director of housing was coming from was
would be consultant with just our
Council tenants on what they feel is a
suitable service we have to do that as
part of the engagement strategy that was
approved only a few weeks ago and the
regulator will also be looking at that
in future months to come forward but
it's not with our private it's not with
uh owner occupiers private landlords
it's with our social housing tenants
that we will be engaging with to see
what service they want
and the whole reason that we decided to
transfer that money across was as has
already been explained is that the
hundred thousand that was has been put
aside uh in previous years was just not
sufficient to cover this type of service
that we wanted to do in our open space
for our Council tenants as councilors
you would have been getting complaint
after complaint that the h on one of our
Council developments wasn't being cut
the lawn wasn't being cut it wasn't
being kept the weeds weren't being kept
down so that hundred thousand just was
not sufficient to cost to cover those
costs so the decision was made to
transfer more monies across to the
general fund so that we could deliver a
much better service on our Open Spaces
on our Council developments thank you Mr
Chen
Deborah I think it was come back in on
that earthquake as well thank you thank
you and also to remind members that we
are obliged under the consumer
regulations the tenant engagement
um consumer standard to
um to to engage and consult with our
residents so
um councilor Osborne is absolutely
correct this is about
um following up and engaging and asking
residents what they want uh but that
said
um of course there is a cost to all this
and if
um some residents opt to our
um an increased service on public realm
that there will be a cost to that and
that cost
um will have to be reflected in in
service charge
um so so that's the the kind of work
which um I'm talking about and the work
will be carried out by the housing team
in partnership with
um the the public realm so so we
wouldn't be expecting uh the public
realm team the operatives to go out and
consult with with residents it will be
an in-house housing function
Council apart
so it sounds like we're going to have
quite bizarre situation emerging where
um our housing tenants are going to
potentially have a better standard of
public realm than our other tenants
quite possibly
some more interesting
um can I just check with you Mark
um on this new resource that you you all
is being allocated to to your team
um is is that
human resource or is that mechanical
sweeper
that sort of resource
primarily it's Grounds Maintenance and
cleansing team resource to work
specifically in how we're not we're not
anticipating or trying to design a dual
standard we're just trying to address
an historic underinvestment and historic
lack of service which is reflected in a
number of complaints you've been getting
and that will allow Deborah and her team
as they develop their tenant Services
strategy further to be in a position
where they can fairly recover recharges
to tenant to expect a better service
there but we don't we don't develop dual
standards of services effectively
yeah well
the area of grass where I live is so
poorly maintained that our residents
decided to take it over and do it
themselves which has been a roaring
success
um well that's great and we'll work with
that tenant group as well in that
position if they can do that and help to
support our budgets and services and
we'll provide our services around that
as as well really yeah you're not going
to go out and ask tents like how's
residents like ours whether we're happy
with our service or not
you're not intended to do that we know
we know
we know around the housing area
it's people resources we're recruiting
for that started recruitment of that
um now commencing that process and it'll
also be vehicles and it'll be mowers and
all the equipment that needs to go with
together with that team
um we're not we're not anticipating
changes to things like mechanical street
sweeping which you mentioned other than
being able to access in those areas
have you got the resource where you have
the resource or have you got the
resource now to make sure that both the
large sweeper and the small sweeper are
out nearly every day
every day every every weekday
we have got the resources in place
um it is a challenge we do have one of
our hgv drivers on long-term sicknesses
unfortunately um of suffering from
cancer we don't know whether he'll be
able to return and we do have a
mechanism within the team where we can
support it with other hgv trained
drivers for the two hgv level sweepers
that we've got um
evaluation process on those roles which
is going through to look at what we're
paying there in terms of Market rates to
address competitive issues that we've
had on the hdv drivers as well so that's
that's I know it's an issue you've
raised and we've responded to it
thank you
any other questions
Council Lindsay
um just on the table too and capital
financing charges
the big uh jump in um interest payable
other
the big ger change in the
the two key factors here are up until
recently we've had very short-term loans
so we've been managing to
take the benefit of having low interest
rates
those short-term loans are coming to an
end now so we're having to refinance and
obviously interest rates
so
expensive time
I seem to have covered the general fund
and a fair bit of that housing revenue
account as well anything else on either
of those two funds
come on the interest
ing so is it just do we
it's just very unlucky that we've
um had to refinance just as interest
rates
just after Liz truss has sent interest
rates up or um
or it's sorry for that I'll I'll
withdraw that just after interest rates
have sword or is it do we have to
refinance every year well with
short-term interest do you potentially
have to keep fight refinancing don't you
because it's short term
this doesn't include any increase in
capital borrowings it's just a refinance
the loan
and the argument I mean we take
professional advice this is not a
Consultants as to which way we should go
what interest rates are going to do I
think the interest rate rise Court most
people by surprise
um and there the experts are not saying
this is what you should be doing now
given the the perhaps the future
environment for interest rates so maybe
the switch to slightly longer term
investment um the interest
I want to look for other sources of
Finance
yeah
is it unlucky
it would have been nice to have had
perhaps long-term loans fixed for 50
years at one percent but um
we didn't go down that route
I think anybody who
[Music]
equally mystified by interest rates and
the way they go up and down and round
and round
just be thankful that we haven't got it
in Bitcoins or any of these digital
currencies because that would have
really potentially produced a nightmare
any other point I think maybe I mean is
it I imagine we need to have short-term
borrowings because we so we can
have it ready access to what accesses
and readies you know
um so so we've got to take the risk a
bit of sudden interest rate movements
because because we need some short-term
borrowings all the time always
be out of place to say but we're
actually looking potentially tomorrow
from our cousins in Midsouth
of course short-term short-term
borrowing comes from lots of different
places and same as we
also lend out some of our
reserves so we're getting income back in
as well from from that sucks also it's
that
I won't say it's a win-win situation
because it isn't but it's a it's a
a Movable Feast which I think our
officers do a pretty good job of trying
to keep track of
any other points
Council I might just say it's just
interesting to you know even when it's
looking most dire
it seems that the funds come through and
I think you have to bear that in mind
each year when we're faced with quite
difficult decisions that we're being
asked to make about cutting services or
um or or or or or sort of adjusting
adjusting downwards the funds come
through the government doesn't generally
make letters let us falter does it so we
it's useful to know that when we're
facing the next year that we're often
often in this position where where our
Gap in funding is
uh looking manageable at the end of the
year
one of the things that never ceases to
amaze me are all the different funds
that the government gets involved in in
either setting up or remove
D moving around and adjusting the
balances of them and it's a it's a
difficult job to put together a budget
when you
are anticipating what might happen and
I think we're fortunate we have been
looking at it now for before Christmas
and again now it's enabled us to have a
constructive look at things and see how
things are going
well if nobody's got any more questions
do we need to make a recommendation or
are we content and to just note this
report
well I have made I have made a note of
that and in actual fact the next item on
the agenda is to do with the work plan
so we can of course add it to the work
plan
on that item
so we won't get lost it'll be added into
the notepad and carried forward in that
respect
so
Council Osborne's said his proposal just
noted
second or fluoride
Council Dawson all those in favor
I'm not going to do an electronic boat
for six of us
thank you that's that's carried
which moves us on to the forthcoming
decisions list to members that it's
everybody's got it I've seen a copy of
it
anybody have any
comment from forthcoming decisions list
no
they move move on then from to the work
plan which is where I think we all have
a we need a proposal to
add in but we have a look at
the ground's maintenance public realm
and the question is where to put it it's
probably going to have to be after the
election now
in March we've got the the sewage we
don't want my treatment
how long Mark how long do you think
um we would need on something like uh
late Mark public
um it depends what you're after really
to be honest I can go back through and
I'll work with Melissa and work with
public realm and review the position
that came across from Heidi Verdi and
where we are as probably aware our
corporate manager
Jeff World virtuals moving on to a new
role at the moment so I'm in the in the
process of recruiting his replacement at
the moment so it's not necessarily a
night
a highways contract for Norfolk County
council with wsp so which is a great
shame
um
but obviously yeah so
it's a really great shame so
the thought carrying out early
including Wheels replacement is not
ideal for my own perspective but if
that's what you want we'll we'll fit it
in as soon as you can
well
we've had we've
[Music]
uh well that's the world's still there
till the end of March he's on three
month notice period And if required the
recruitment's underway at the moment if
required we might put in
that's all
yeah
okay well I'll I'll I will take it up
with um with the officers and with
public realm and we'll sort that if we
can put it into March then when we have
our February meeting you'll see it on
the March work plan I mean I'll look
we'll we'll have a look at it before the
end of March and we'll try and fit that
in for you yeah it's nothing yeah we're
not trying to hide anything here Council
of Dawson to not to try and put things
off until after the election let's try
and sort them out now
let's make use of his his talents before
he disappears
are you are you counselors are you
contend to note the uh the existing work
plan and we'll look at the modified one
with this extra item on it next to the
next meeting
Council Osborne yes
second
councilor Barrett all in favor
everybody thank you very much indeed for
that
which brings us on to uh
Council Lindsay do you want right sorry
chair I I I was I just thought I'll keep
quiet and then I thought no actually I I
was waiting for you to say now we're
moving to the HRA account because I had
a question on the HRA account and then
we suddenly had to vote on the whole
thing I didn't realize it I thought I
did actually say that we've been dealing
with both the HRA fund account and uh I
wasn't and then okay you have an
additional question on the HRA account
yeah well we'll hear it now um well it
was it was just simply
the big increase in repairs
um pressures you know 1.7 million it's
the biggest item under the pressures
um
it's not just inflation is it what's
what's behind that
must have materials
salaries I think perhaps the most
important thing of all is this the the
state of our housing Supply I think we
anticipate that there's going to be an
awful lot of work
needed
bring the housing Supply up to scratch
I think it's probably fair to say as
well councilor Lindsay when it comes to
repairs that the cost of raw materials
for for any repair job have gone out
through the roof
everybody who's been out and bought
Timber recently for any carpentry work
or anything like that or
anything to do with building the prices
have gone out through the roof we is one
of the reasons why we can consistently
see in the in the press that the big
house builders are
reducing their targets for house
building in the next year because
they're obviously seeing it as well and
don't want don't think that they'll be
able to get it back in terms of resale
prices of the properties
so is it you talked about the state of
the housing you've got
um is it fair to say there's a backlog
building up are we confident that
backlog is being reduced the backlog of
repair work uh if there is one or is it
increasing
could answer but I'm sure Jan will give
her much more
thank you Mr chairman
um actually we are gradually reducing
the backlog there was a huge backlog
because of covid lockdown where there
was a two years where we couldn't go
into people's properties and then when
we could they didn't want us going in
for safety reasons which is
understandable so there was a huge
backlog that backlog is gradually
diminishing slowly but surely
in regards to
um the where the properties are
deteriorating we've got properties that
are built in the 60s 70s
and you wouldn't even have them built
nowadays
um so they do become very expensive when
you're trying to repair and maintain
them so that's another issue to the to
the rising costs and as David Busby's
already alluded to the cost of materials
went up by 24.3 that's a huge rise in
materials so if you add all that
together hence why we've um we've got
that rise in costs as well and I think
it's fair to say if we look back on what
we allocate we used to allocate so much
for maintenance for each property we
underestimated we didn't estimate enough
we're now getting into with the
transformation work that's going on the
diagnostic review we'll get into a
position where we know exactly how much
each property is going to cost us in
three four five years time so we get a
much more balanced budget as we move
forward but that will take a little time
to get there but we are getting there
so members are are we happy that we've
had got all the questions out of the way
for housing and general fund
okay well that brings us to the end of
this baber agenda
there will now be a short intermission
until we round up the mid-suffet for The
Joint part
get them in a bit earlier then we'll see
if we can get them in a bit earlier if
they're here
will give us a little bit more of a
break before the council meeting this
evening